>> Harris: THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IN FOCUS NOW REPUBLICAN
NATIONAL COMMITTEE CHAIRWOMAN
RONNA McDANIEL.
GREAT TO SEE YOU TODAY.
FIRST OF ALL, LET’S START WITH
WHERE OR HOW AMERICANS WILL
IMMEDIATELY FEEL A QUADRUPLEING
OF THE CAP OF REFUGEES TO THE
UNITED STATES.
>> THESE BORDER STATES AND
BORDER PERSONNEL WILL BE
UNINDATED EVEN MORE.
WHAT JOE BIDEN KEEPS DOING IS
PUTTING A MAGNET OUT TO DRAW
PEOPLE TO THIS COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY PUTTING THEM IN
HARM’S WAY, PUTTING THEM IN THE
HANDS OF CARTELS WHO THEY HAVE
TO PAY TO MAKE THIS DANGEROUS
TREK AND IT IS IMPACTING
CHILDREN AT A SIGNIFICANT RATE.
MANY ARE DYING AS THEY MAKE
THIS JOURNEY.
INSTEAD OF SAYING LET’S TACKLE
THE IMMIGRATION PROBLEM AND
HAVE IMMIGRATION REFORM, HE
KEEPS THROWING QUICK FIXES OUT
THERE THAT APPEASE THE DEMOCRAT
PROGRESSIVE LEFT WITHOUT
ACTUALLY SOLVING A ROOT PROBLEM
AND BOY, I FEEL SO BAD FOR OUR
BORDER PATROL AGENTS WHO ARE SO
OVERWHELMED RIGHT NOW AND THEY
HAVE A PRESIDENT AND WHITE
HOUSE WHO DOESN’T CARE ABOUT
THEM AND THE TASK THEY ARE
UNDERTAKING.
>> Harris: IT IS INTERESTING TO
HEAR YOU TALK DIRECTLY ABOUT
THE FAMILIES, REFUGEES
PARTICULARLY AND THE CHILDREN
BECAUSE WE KNOW THE PRESSURE
THAT IS HAPPENING AT THE BORDER
RIGHT NOW IN TERMS OF
PROTECTING CHILDREN AND WHAT A
HUGE JOB IT IS AS YOU POINT OUT
FOR THE BORDER PATROL.
ALBANIAN REFUGEE SAYS BIDEN’S
DECISION TO RAISE THE REFUGEE
CAP IS NOT ABOUT HELPING
PEOPLE, THOUGH.
WATCH THIS.
>> WHY INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
REFUGEES NOW?
WHAT IS THE INTENT?
THE INTENT OF THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY IS TO CREATE A PERMANENT
UNDERCLASS IN THE UNITED STATES
SO IT CAN BE DEPENDENT ON THE
GOVERNMENT AND CREATE A VOTING
BLOCK FOR THE FUTURE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
WE SHOULD UNDERSTAND THE INTENT
IS NOT TO BRING THESE PEOPLE TO
GET THEM OUT OF MISERY AND OUT
OF SUFFERING.
>> Harris: THAT’S AN
INTERESTING FIRST PERSON
PERSPECTIVE.
YOUR REACTION TO IT.
>> I THINK HE IS DOING
TREMENDOUS HARM TO THESE
FAMILIES WHO ARE COMING HERE
WITH HOPE AND WANT TO COME TO
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
BUT ARE BEING PUT IN THE HANDS
OF CARTELS.
I TALKED TO GOVERNOR ABBOTT
LAST WEEK.
HE SAID THERE ISN’T A SINGLE
PERSON COMING ACROSS OUR BORDER
WHO ISN’T BEING DEALT WITH FOR
THE CARTELS.
THEY HAVE TO PAY THE CARTELS.
MANY CHILDREN ARE DYING ALONG
THE WAY AND SUFFERING HORRIFIC
ABUSES AS THEY COME TO THIS
COUNTRY.
NOT ONLY WILL THE PRESIDENT AND
VICE PRESIDENT GO TO THE BORDER
THEY HAVEN’T SPOKEN TO THE
GOVERNORS DEALING WITH THIS
FIRSTHAND.
HE IS PUTTING A POLICY IN PLACE.
HE KEEPS AOC AND DURBIN AND THE
PROGRESSIVE LEFT HAPPY BUT IT
IS A CATASTROPHE FOR EVERYBODY
WHO IS DEALING WITH IT IN
REALTIME IN OUR SOUTHERN STATES.
>> Harris: HOW IS IT THAT THE
PROGRESSIVES ON THE HILL HAVE
MORE PRESSURE AND CAN GET MORE
EFFECTIVE ACTION FROM THIS
PRESIDENT THAN MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS?
>> HE RAN AS A MODERATE, HARRIS.
WE KNOW THIS.
HE RAN AS I WILL UNITE PEOPLE.
WE SAW HIS INAUGURAL SPEECH.
HE HAS BEEN NOTHING BUT.
HE HAS SPOKEN MORE TO XI AND
PUTIN THAN TO MCCARTHY AND
MCCONNELL.
HE HAS NO INTEREST WORKING
ACROSS THE AISLE.
IT’S TELLING THEY HAVEN’T GONE
TO THE BORDER AND TALKED TO THE
AGENTS AND TALKED TO THE
FAMILIES AND TALKED TO THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE DEALING WITH
THIS CRISIS FIRSTHAND.
AND THAT SHOWS THAT HE IS NOT
REALLY INTERESTED IN SOLVING
THE PROBLEM.
HE IS INTERESTED IN GIVING TO
HIS PROGRESSIVE FRIENDS AND
MAKING SURE THEY GET THEIR WIN.
>> Harris: WE HEARD THAT ONE
ALBANIAN REFUGEE TALK ABOUT
BIDEN IS NOT FOCUSED ON HELPING
THE CHILDREN.
HERE ARE SOME CHILDREN THAT
MAYBE CAN GET THE PRESIDENT’S
ATTENTION DIFFERENT SUBJECT.
SOME FIFTH GRADERS IN VIRGINIA
WENT OFF SCRIPT.
THEY WERE TO TELL THE PRESIDENT
AND FIRST LADY WHAT REMOTE
LEARNING HAS BEEN LIKE.
>> ONE STUDENT SAID IT WAS
TERRIBLE.
WE HAVE CHILDREN.
WE KNOW FIRSTHAND CHAIRWOMAN
WHAT THE JOURNEY HAS BEEN LIKE.
ONE-THIRD OF STUDENTS JUST TO
REMIND EVERYBODY STILL IN THE
UNITED STATES RIGHT NOW ARE NOT
GETTING FULL-TIME IN-PERSON
LEARNING.
A CUP OF TRUTH FROM THE KIDS.
>> I THINK IT’S THE FIRST TIME
THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN TOOK
UNSCRIPTED QUESTIONS OR TALKING
POINTS FROM CHILDREN.
I ALSO THINK IT’S INTERESTING
THAT THE CDC IS TAKING THEIR
GUIDANCE FROM TEACHERS UNIONS.
MAYBE THEY SHOULD TALK TO THE
CHILDREN.
THIS IS WHAT IT’S ABOUT.
KIDS WHO ARE LACKING IN
EDUCATION, WHO AREN’T GETTING
THAT IN-PERSON INSTRUCTION, WHO
ARE GETTING A GAP IN WHAT THEY
NEED TO GET AHEAD.
I THINK TIM SCOTT PUT IT SO
WELL IN HIS SPEECH SAYING KIDS
BEING LOCKED OUT OF THE
CLASSROOM TODAY ARE OUR FUTURE
ADULTS BEING LOCKED OUT OF
THEIR POTENTIAL AND IT’S SO
TRUE.
I HAVE A SON THAT’S IN VIRTUAL.
I WOULD BE HAPPY FOR HIM TO
PICK UP THE PHONE AND TALK TO
PRESIDENT BIDEN ABOUT HOW AWFUL
IT IS FOR HIM.
IT IS REALLY, REALLY
CATASTROPHIC FOR THESE KIDS.
I DEAL WITH IT FIRSTHAND AND
SAD THIS ADMINISTRATION IS
PUTTING THE UNIONS ABOVE THE
CHILDREN.
THAT’S THE PROBLEM ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY NOW.
DEMOCRATS ARE PUTTING THE
UNIONS ABOVE THE SCIENCE AND
THE CHILDREN BECAUSE WE KNOW
IT’S SAFE FOR THEM TO GO BACK
IN THE CLASSROOM RIGHT NOW.
>> Harris: CHAIRWOMAN RONNA
McDANIEL I WANT TO GET TO THIS
BEFORE I LET YOU GO.
DEMOCRATS ARE LOCKED OUT OF A
TEXAS RUNOFF ELECTION.
THAT RACE WILL NOW SEE TWO
REPUBLICANS FACING OFF FOR A
CONGRESSIONAL SEAT IN TEXAS.
A "WASHINGTON POST" OP-ED IS
SAYING IT’S A  -- THE SUBURBS
SNAP BACK AND REPUBLICANS LOCK
STEP.
YOU AND I HAVE TALKED SO MANY
TIMES ABOUT HOW PRODUCTIVE AND
SUCCESSFUL THE RNC HAS BEEN AT
THE DOOR KNOCKS.
IMAGINE POST -- A TIME WHEN
MANY PEOPLE ARE FULLY
VACCINATED POST THAT TIME WHEN
PEOPLE MIGHT NOT OPEN THEIR
DOORS.
IS THAT OP-ED RIGHT IF YOU GET
BACK OUT THERE NOW?
>> WE WERE KNOCKING DOORS, WE
CONTACTED 4,000 VOTERS TO GET
THEM OUT.
WE KNEW WE HAD TO TARGET LIKELY
REPUBLICANS IN THAT DISTRICT
AND THE DEMOCRATS DID IT TOO.
THEY WERE FIGHTING FOR THE SEAT.
DON’T LET THEM PRETEND THEY
WERE WALKING AWAY.
THEIR BEST CHANCE TO FLIP A
HOUSE SEAT AND RAN 11 POINTS
BEHIND JOE BIDEN IN 2020.
THIS IS HUGE FOR REPUBLICANS
THAT WE WALKED AWAY WITH TWO
REPUBLICANS IN THE RUNOFF AND
WE’LL PICK UP ANOTHER HOUSE
SEATS THAT SHRINKS NANCY
PELOSI’S MARGIN HEADING INTO
2022.
FIVE SEATS AWAY FROM TAKING
BACK THE MAJORITY.
>> Harris: JUST ABOUT EVERY
PRESIDENT LOSES IN THE FIRST
MID-TERM.
A RESETTING POINT.
THEY KIND OF LIKE A LITTLE
SPLIT GOVERNMENT.
BLOODBATH IS STRONG LANGUAGE
FOR THE "WASHINGTON POST".
WHAT IS YOUR QUICK TAKE ON HOW
BAD IT COULD BE?
>> I NEVER WANT TO GET
COMFORTABLE.
I WANT EVERYBODY TO WORK HARD.
WE CAN TAKE BACK THE HOUSE.
IT IS FIVE SEATS AWAY.
USUALLY IT’S 26 SEATS IN A
MID-TERM.
REPUBLICANS HAVE TO SHOW UP.
WE HAVE TO BE UNITED.
LET’S REMEMBER WHAT JOE BIDEN
IS DOING TO THIS COUNTRY AND
NOT FOCUS ON OUR INNER DISPUTES.
WE HAVE TO WORK TOGETHER IF
WE’LL WIN AND TAKE BACK THE
HOUSE IN 2022.